-And now here for a performance
from Broadway's
"Freestyle Love Supreme"
with a little help
from Questlove,
Lin-Manuel Miranda,
Anthony Veneziale,
Utkarsh Ambudkar, Aneesa Folds,
Chris Sullivan, Arthur Lewis,
and Bill Sherman.
-And Bill.
-Thank you so very much, Jimmy.
We are, in fact,
Freestyle Love Supreme.
-'Preme, 'Preme.
-'Preme, 'Preme, 'Preme.
-And we need your help because
our show is completely made up.
-Wow.
-It is all improvised.
Without you, we can't do it.
And we, of course, are called
Freestyle Love Supreme.
-'Preme, 'Preme, 'Preme.
-But we don't love everything.
It's pretty hard to love
everything nowadays, am I right?
-The world's on fire.
-Hi-oh.
So why don't we talk about some
things maybe you don't love?
Maybe you don't even like them.
Dare I say you might
dislike them?
What are some things
you are disliking right now?
-Tomatoes!
-Tomatoes.
-Mayonnaise!
-Mayonnaise.
What else?
-Bunions.
-Bunions? All right. Well done.
Yeah?
-College.
-College. Nice.
-Open seating in offices.
-They're great.
-Bunions.
-College.
-College. We have all three
of our suggestions.
On the far side of stage,
we have...
-College.
-In the middle, we have...
-Open-seating offices.
-And on the right we have...
-Bunions.
-Without further ado,
these are a few of your
least-favorite things.
-[ Imitating wind rushing ]
♪♪
-♪ Skerp. skerp, skerp ♪
-♪ Yeah, I'm Indian,
parents both PhD's ♪
♪ So they really tried
to educate me ♪
♪ Went to a college,
got knowledge in my neck ♪
♪ But now I'm in debt, debt,
mother F'in debt ♪
♪ Why the F can't I pay
any of my bills? ♪
♪ Don't stop me now ♪
♪ Every single night,
all I'm eating is that ramen ♪
♪ And I don't even know
what I do when I'm not sober ♪
♪ 'Cause I wipe my own booty
with my college diploma ♪
-♪ First day of work,
and I'm feeling so great ♪
♪ Grateful for having
a job on my plate ♪
♪ Walk into the office,
and it's not that I'm bitter ♪
♪ But everyone can see me
every time I check Twitter ♪
♪ Yo, open-plan seating
is not the mood ♪
♪ I'm tryin' to do some work ♪
♪ I don't have
any daylight to proof ♪
♪ And, yo, I'm tryin' to do ♪
♪ A little
extracurricular activity ♪
♪ But this is doing damage ♪
♪ To my long-term proclivity ♪
-♪ Swipin' on Tinder,
just met this guy ♪
♪ From the looks of his picture,
he's lookin' real fly ♪
♪ We go to the spot
to get something to eat ♪
♪ And then I take
a quick glance at his feet ♪
♪ Oh, why! ♪
♪ Why I'm smelling onions? ♪
♪ This dude has eight, nine,
ten, eleven bunions ♪
♪ Get outta here,
I just came to eat a meal ♪
♪ What's going on, dude? ♪
♪ Tell me, what's your deal? ♪
-♪ Yeah, a college education
is troublin' ♪
♪ Don't ask me ask,
ask Felicity Huffman ♪
♪ What the freakin' hell? ♪
♪ Why you trying to get
your kids in on a bribe? ♪
♪ I don't know,
college, college gotta die ♪
-♪ Still hungover
from our date on Sunday ♪
♪ Karen comes over ♪
♪ Looks like
a case of the Mondays ♪
♪ Go away, Karen,
can I have my own office? ♪
♪ Can I do my own job
and get my own job office? ♪
-♪ Halfway through the date,
he's asking me how it's goin' ♪
♪ And then he asked me
if I'd be into suckin' toes ♪
♪ And, no, I don't want that,
please get your feet ♪
♪ I'm only two, four seconds
away from leaving my seat ♪
-♪ Don't go to college,
trust me, save your money ♪
♪ Instead be like us,
you could rap and be funny ♪
-♪ I'm not trying
to be a jerk ♪
♪ I'm just trying
to go to work ♪
♪ Will you leave me alone? ♪
♪ Well, leave me alone
'cause I am just going berserk ♪
-♪ This guy really thinks
this date is going the best ♪
♪ What in the CeeLo Green
the hell is this mess? ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-But, seriously, don't be
one of those late huggers
coming to see me at the office
on Wednesday.
♪♪
-Freestyle Love Supreme.
-'Preme, 'Preme, 'Preme, 'Preme.
-Oh, my goodness!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wow!
You can catch
"Freestyle Love Supreme"
now at the Booth Theatre.
For tickets, go to
freestylelovesupreme.com.
Yeah, you get a standing O.
Why not? That's well-deserved.
That's great.
-Yeah, yeah.